[Musique]
antoinette hommes évoluent à 45 mètres
du sol à la recherche de roche instable
leur mission
enlever toutes les pierres qui
pourraient menacer les randonneurs
circulant sur les sentiers en contrebas
toutes ces masses qui ont été
répertoriés urgente
on va les démonter donc on va aller on
les confine derrière un derrière un
grillage et ensuite on fait du carottage
à l'aide d'un éclateur hydraulique
on va fract fractionner les morceaux
pour obtenir des petits morceaux et
ensuite les descendre en bas il faut
dire que cette roche calcaire vieille de
160 millions d'années et
particulièrement friable les études
effectuées ces trois dernières années
ont montré que cette sécurisation était
indispensable
malgré son coût c'est un investissement
humain permanent parce que c'est quand
même un lieu magique c'est un lieu
symbolique de la saône et loire de la
bourgogne du sud
elle aurait coûté investissements il est
environ deux cent cinq mille euros hors
taxes plus des 1000 euros dus à la co
vide ça engendre et comme tout le monde
le sait des frais annexes et cela et je
tiens à le dire c'est entièrement
financé par le conseil départemental de
saône et loire
au total près de cent mètres cubes de
pierres seront retirés sur neuf zones du
site de solutré les travaux devraient
durer entre cinq et six semaines
[Musique]